[Music]
I also go Ambrose
my name is Pierre bad welcome back to
afraid of smash nice and the last
episode I was really good really clever
move on me I must say took me about half
an hour anyway we can jump here and kill
her okay that was not as that was this
plan of course just to intimidate hey
what is this not smash knees solves
everything alright good actually through
alright um I mean you should be able
like nice quick sake
yep yes like a pouch nah Oh like a loser
no no I was just testing the games yes
that's how I roll [ __ ] smash these to
celebrate all right not a lot of people
understand smash nice it's
understandable
[ __ ] yeah oh no he smacked me he smack
me back off back off back the [ __ ] all
right I gotta teach him a lesson
I know i teleported away oh this is cozy
he lived here Wow
I don't know I'm out of batteries hey
but what is this yeah dis just awesome
alright and I got boxes smash knees
smash knees I more drugs
I mean pillow sorry I don't know
God as long as there aren't any dragons
I'm good right what did we get we have
this room oh god [ __ ] damn it that's
a lot of [ __ ] zombies boom gotta get
that boom boom boom gotta get that bomb
boom thank you alright holy Sh huh
let's back up back the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
ah alright I can probably my hair so
[ __ ] many of them back why did I even
go in
god dammit I barely any ammo left all
right I better save this for tricky
situations F - all right one headshot
[ __ ] ugh god damn it I miss hi he has a
helmet I don't know if smash knees will
work smash this I get them and he
touched it smash nice smash nice
that's what I'm talking bad wife is
still sunning sounds creepy
alright
oh dude don't [ __ ] do that
don't you dare do that goddamn I have to
redo that oh my god that scared me a lot
all right I got a guy teaching my lesson
of smash knees here
why did he [ __ ] did he come from though
I don't like this it's true bright
beauty I'm sorry I'm not the game
developer
all right continue PR [ __ ] you smash me
out
are you [ __ ] Pole come on haha
alright join I really don't have
anything else and four shots
zero shot alright smashing is it's it's
a rule of the game name of the game I
wanna okay let's just go come here buddy
come anybody come here buddy
come on buddy oh you're stuck too
[ __ ] bad I don't care smash nice ah
come on I have to shoot this little
[ __ ] or run away from them let's go
with the runaway part blue car I love
blue card oh god that mean he just
follows me what is this all it's a ah
stop ah
I'm sorry I I'm not the one who decides
this all right two shots kill some holy
[ __ ] okay let's look at this we are well
we got this here and I guess we need it
I think I know where we need it actually
already cuz I'm so slow oh no oh oh oh I
need to pee yeah oh my god Wow alright
we need to move this [ __ ] box
backwards I know how you do that oh you
just holy okay I saw a ladder here so
I'm thinking hey there's pills up from
that thing how do I jump up on this
alright sweet maybe we can find more
stuff yes I see peels over there what
epic jump whip more drugs I love drugs
so much all right what do guys here what
is this
ah that shotgun ammo
I gave out oh yes yes
Smt Oh or UMP or whatever [ __ ] it is all
right okay now we go here [ __ ]
[ __ ] snikt snikt whatever I got them
all right that's what I'm talking about
right there
yes I don't know what's going on it
isn't moving
oh it goes there and then I get all
genius I thought of that before you
thought of that have full health I have
a freaking SMG mag but just be snitchin
like snitches no no that's not how we do
it in this game right I have an SMG
though it's cool yeah yeah that's what I
thought yeah yeah I did that I did whoop
and then I work and I was a gear hey
more bottoms I love buttons all right
I'm gonna click get Hey all right that's
what I'm talking about we escape the
garage oh wait take the blue car I'm
outta here but just finally aah
BAM this is also alright now I'm out of
here
so we finish the game no we're not even
close I'm sorry then the second mod that
he's making
maybe it is finished now it's impossible
anyway the second model the developer of
this is Maggie needs to be making it
forever
and this is really look at that and
looking really good a little really good
and it comes out in a month so I'm
hoping I could finish this before then I
can't wait to play that game it's called
afraid of monsters I already spoke about
it all right but just keep on driving
forgive me thank you
I forgive you school
[Music]
I don't know what's going on all I know
it's like we're a drug addict
I'm guessing it's all a dream or
something like that
like who hallucinations
I don't really know I don't even know
and I do can I steer
it looks like attending here
[Music]
all right continuous sweet worried that
it's gonna finish alright where are we
all right we're on we're in the [ __ ]
box
that's pretty [ __ ] disturbing down
sounds like beatboxing nice beatboxing
bro
whoa I don't like this alright
we're got drugs I ordered Apfel health
because I'm such a boss the arrow is
telling me to go all right I can trust
there I don't know
Oh back the [ __ ] up oh god you're so
deserving I'm sorry a game I'm sorry I
should have listened to you I gave me
pills at least that's very nice
I don't like it
Oh
all right as it is inserted by Barrow
hello
[ __ ] the [ __ ] up oh no oh no I smash
nice [ __ ]
ah no not again god damn it all right
come here come at me bro
smash nice smash nice that's what I'm
talking about
you spoke to my handler and that's what
you own no I'm out of wait what did I
roll say all right
ah
all right this way
Oh
oh god I'm so [ __ ] here I'm so [ __ ]
[ __ ] back the [ __ ] up [ __ ] I needed
that
I have screwed as hell I hang ain't got
no [ __ ] ham on
I'm out of buy this
same here
[ __ ] okay I bet early started listening
- hell even [ __ ] kill me all right
focus pity
you can do this
and uh a cups
alright go watching like a boss
yes alright commander brush that don't
mind repulsion of that all right back up
back up
are you serious haha come on that wasn't
it tired
that was really
Maya P alright nothing like a mouse now
she's been like about all right coming
right right right
[ __ ] they have a lot out
[ __ ] yeah no not anybody please
don't [ __ ] focus alright alright
needs fight too smart no don't speak
smash name yes come out I can do this I
didn't do it I was so harsh ah
smash knees I pick it up for [ __ ] sake
ah come on
guys I die
die die die all right one more I can
deal with you you little [ __ ]
I spoke shot smart yes
yes oh no he's like alright okay I have
one [ __ ] health absolutely no mo
yeah sorry
stop
all right please no more I come
both sides [ __ ] this is really difficult
god damn this is difficult alright
let's go yes
[ __ ] you I don't even know what I'm I
died all right I can't go there so wait
let me just
all right keep on throwing it I'll bet
all right thank you
remember on scare bra
ah come on one hit and I'm down Yusuke
bra
there you go happy food ah ah come on I
got this is way too difficult ah ah
he went down how is it possible hahaha
come the [ __ ] on
yes taste it bet yes
alright I'll deal with other one camara
yes oh now he's face
yes yes all right let's keep our Charlie
and it's fine ever
crazy [ __ ] man
okay there's no way for me to progress
I'm supposed to go there I have no
[ __ ] hell
hi this way
how am I supposed to go there without
dying how it's impossible
explain it to me
hike around Mira [ __ ] Oh God
for anyone that's not a good way to say
that's definitely not a good place to
say that's a horrible place to say I
guess wow I'm gonna end it here bro
hope you enjoyed I think I need to
figure something out until the next like
a favorite if you did subscribe to come
home bro today and I'll see you tomorrow
hey comes to brofist
[Music]
Oh